Kevin Bacon?
And Michael Bacon.
Michael Bacon?
The Bacon brothers?
Exactly.
We're here to teach you about the power of waking up to eggs.
'Cause who knows eggs better than the Bacon brothers?
Yeah, I get that part.
Why are you in our house, Kevin Bacon?
And Michael Bacon.
And Michael Bacon!
That's it, I'm calling the police.
Oh, check this out.
We are not just in your house, we're lying in your bed.
Drop the phone, pick up six grams of protein instead.
High quality protein, no sugar or carbs, all for 70 calories.
Yeah?
'Cause we've been in here, watching you sleeping all night long.
Just to wake you up to eggs and sing you this song.
E G G S, E G G S, E G G S, eggs.
Your wife is beautiful.
You ready, Mike?
Sure.
We're outta here.